meine Lieben Zuschauer das heutige Video
wird euch von Dungeon Hunter 6
präsentiert Dungeon Hunter feiert mit
seinem sechsten Teil nämlich einen
bombastischen Neustart der beliebten
Handy Hack and Slay Reihe dieses
fantastische kostenlose Spiel für
Android und iOS bietet actionreiche
Kämpfe bei denen jede Taktik zählt ihr
könnt alleine losziehen oder euch mit
Freunden zusammenschließen um in
Echtzeit gemeinsam in die Schlacht zu
ziehen mit über 100 einzigartigen und
Liebe voll designen Bossen aus
verschiedenen Fantasy reichen steht euch
eine riesige Auswahl zur Verfügung dabei
basiert jeder Boss auf einem
ausgeglügelten Konzept mit individuellen
Fähigkeiten und angriffsmustern und
eines kann ich euch versprechen jeder
Bossgegner bietet durch seine
spezifischen Eigenschaft ein
einzigartiges Spielerlebnis aber wartet
denn der eigentliche klug das wirklich
innovative Feature von Dungeon Hunter 6
ist dass ihr besiegte Bosse nicht nur
plündern sondern sie auch in eure
Dienste zwingen könnt ihr könnt auf
ihnen reiten oder bis zu drei von ihnen
beschwören um an eurer Seite zu kämpfen
mit der Zeit könnt ihr sogar ihre
Gestalt annehmen um ihre gewaltige Macht
zu entfesseln stellt euch also auf auf
actionreiche Kämpfe ein bei denen ihr
eure gesamten bossgefolgsleute einsetzt
um noch mächtigere Bosse zu bezwingen
hinzu kommen kreative Gameplayelemente
wie die katenverwandlung für
Schleichmissionen oder das Reiten
verschiedener Fantasy Kreaturen bei
Multiplayer die atberaubenden 3D
Grafiken sind zudem optimal auf euer
Handy angepasst und sorgen durch die
detailreichen Animationen für ein
flüssiges Spielerlebnis zusätzlich
bietet Dungeon Hunter sechs verschiedene
Skillbäume zum Anpassen eures Charakters
ein Auktionssystem für den Handel mit
anderen Spielern sowie Echtzeit
Gildenkriege für multiplayer action die
Fachpresse lobdungeon hter se für sein
innovatives bosssystem die
abwechslungsreichen Kämpfe und die
motivierende Charakterentwicklung und um
die nach 8 Jahren lang erwartete
bombastische neuauflagegebühren zu
feiern haben wir ein spezielles Angebot
für alle Neuspieler wenn ihr Dungeon
Hunter 6 über den Link in der
Beschreibung oder dem Video
herunterladet erhaltet ein Startpaket im
Wert von 50 €. dieses enthält Zeh
beschwörungsrollen eineen
dämonenwolfleutnant ein accessoirset und
vieles mehr aber bealt euch denn genau
jetzt ist der perfekte Zeitpunkt um in
die Welt des brandneuen Dungeon Hunter 6
einzutauchen klickt also auf den Link
ladet das Spiel herunter und startet
eure bossjagd mit einem mächtigen
Vorteilspaket wir sehen uns im Dungeon
meine Helden so und wenn ihr euch
genügend im Dungeon vergnügt habt lasst
uns zum Thema dieses Videos kommen und
zwar mit einer kleinen Frage vorab inwi
weit funktionieren überhaupt die
Sanktionen die die internationale
Gemeinschaft nach der Invasion der
Ukraine gegen Russland verhängt hat ich
meine das ist schließlich eine Frage die
immer wieder aufgeworfen wird sie ist
der Ausgangspunkt einer ganzen Debatte
rund um den ukrainekrieg und wisst ihr
was heute werden wir wahrlich Antworten
für jeden Geschmack finden können für
die einen sind die Sanktionen eine
riesiger Misserfolg und natürlich
mangelt es ihnen nicht an Daten die ihre
These untermauern die russische
Kriegsmaschinerie ist nicht zum
Stillstand gekommen die Arbeitslosigkeit
im Land ist niedrig Russlands Wirtschaft
wächst weiter und Inflation bleibt auf
einem vernünftigen Niveau von etwa 5%.
für andere wiederum erdrücken die
Sanktion allmählich die
Produktionskapazitäten Russlands so ist
der Handelsüberschuss zwischen Januar
und August im Vergleich zum Vorjahr um
fast 70% eingebrochen das entspricht
einem Verlust von mehr als 150
Milliarden Dollar logischerweise sind
gleichzeitig auch die Öleinnahmen der
Regierung abgestürzt und das
Haushaltsdefizit ist keine Quelle guter
Nachrichten für den kremmelmeer
natürlich trocknen auch die
investitionszuflüsse ins Land aus und
Auslandsreisen sind teuer und stark
eingeschränkt ein gutes Beispiel dafür
ist auch die Entwicklung des Rubels
trotz aller Kapitalkontrollen fällt die
russische Währung weiter immer wenn sie
die Marke von 100 Rubel pro Dollar reißt
greift der Staat mit Zinserhöhungen
Kapitalverkehrskontrollen und
stützungskäufen ein ja der Rubel ist
noch nicht ganz auf den Status von
monopolly Geld gefallen aber die Grafik
ist nicht gerade schmeichelhaft das
liegt vor allem daran dass die
kapitalabflüsse aus dem Land bereits
größer sind als die Zuflüsse an neuen
Devisen und das ist noch nicht
alles der stetige Wertverlust des Rubels
in Verbindung mit den gestiegenen
Militärausgaben hat den Staat zum
Handeln gezwungen insbesondere musste
die Zentralbank die Zinssätze drastisch
anheben um zu verhindern dass die
Inflation außer Kontrolle gererät wir
sprechen hier von Zinssätzen die bereits
bei 13% liegen und wie ihr euch
vorstellen können sind das nicht die
best Nachrichten für Bürger und
Unternehmer zwischenzeitlich sch
Blomberg die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Russland in den nächsten 6 Monaten in
eine Rezession Gerät auf 21% gegenüber
6% vor etwas mehr als 2 Monaten die
Rezessionswahrscheinlichkeit ist also
immer noch nicht sehr hoch aber der
Trend scheint klar die Lage
verschlechtert
sich wie sieht's also aus funktionieren
die Sanktionen nun die Wahrheit ist dass
es darauf ankommt wenn es darum geht die
russische Kriegsmaschinerie zu stoppen
ist die Wahrheit dass sie nicht absolut
gut Funktion kurzfristig war der Schlag
gegen Russland nur begrenzt aber wenn es
darum geht die wirtschaftlichen und
militärischen Kapazitäten des kremmels
langfristig zu begrenzen dann sind die
Sache schon etwas anders aus denn bei
diesem Zweck könnten die Sanktionen
durchaus Erfolg haben wir werden in
diesem Video nicht über den direkten
Schaden sprechen den die Sanktionen in
der russischen Wirtschaft anrichten über
all das haben wir bereits kürzlich auf
unserem schwesterkanal visualökonomic
gesprochen und ich werde euch das
dortige Video verlinken heute wollen wir
viel mehr ein Thema ansprechen das damit
direkt zusammenhängt aber aus einer ganz
anderen Perspektive wir werden dazu in
eine echte Detektivgeschichte eintauchen
und uns auf die Suche begeben nach den
ganz großen Lex im sanktionswall des
Westens Lex durch die immer noch riesige
Geldsummen fließen und wir werden auch
erschnüffeln über welche dunklen Kanäle
dieses Geld fließt und wo es schließlich
landet aber eins nach dem anderen eine
Studie des Peterson Institute for
International Economics hat ergeben dass
russische Energieunternehmen im Jahr
2022 Vermögen auf undurchsichtigen
Auslandskonten in Höhe von etwa 147
Milliarden Dollar angehäuft haben wohl
gemerkt das war letztes Jahr 2022 aber
in den ersten sech Monaten dieses Jahres
dürfte dieser Topf um weitere 50
Milliarden Dollar angewachsen sein er
wächst also nicht mehr so schnell wie
letztes Jahr aber er wächst noch
insgesamt sprechen wir in anderthalb
Jahren von fast 200 Milliarden Dollar
die sich heute in den Händen von
Giganten wie lukil dem größten
russischen Staatskonzern oder sogar
staatlichen Unternehmen wie rasnft oder
Gasprom befinden wir sprechen hier von
einer beachtlichen Summe in
internationalen Währungen von der viele
Analysten glauben dass Russland damit
seine Kriegsanstrengungen finanzieren
könnte habt ihr z.B diese Nachricht
gesehen die USA warnen Russland
Nordkorea waffengespräche werden aktiv
vorangetrieben nun ja wer weiß
vielleicht wird die Unterstützung B
youngangs größtenteils mit ankel Sams
eigenen Dollars bezahlt ihr wisst bereit
dass das Regime von Kim Jong unsüchtig
nach Dollars ist unter anderem um die
teuren lauden des großen Führers zu
bezahlen und wisst ihr was das alles hat
viel mit einigen sehr wichtigen Fehlern
der Sanktion Progamme zu tun die gegen
Russland verhängt wurden und das hat uns
hier bei visualpolitik veranlasst uns
ein paar Fragen zu stellen wie ist es
möglich dass russische Unternehmen ein
solches Vermögen angehäuft haben inwi
weit umgeht Russland die Sanktionen was
tut der Kremmel sonst noch um sich der
westlichen Bestrafung zu entziehen nun
lasst uns heute zu all diesen Fragen
Antworten finden auf
geht's für jede Regel gibt es ein
Schlupfloch meine lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer von allen Sanktionen die gegen
Russland verhängt wurden um seine
militärischen Kapazitäten einzuschränken
sind zwei der wichtigsten das
einfrierende Auslandsguthaben der
Zentralbank etwa 350 Milliarden Dollar
und zweitens das Ölembargo und die
Festsetzung der berühmten
Preisobergrenze für russisches Rohöl auf
internationaler Ebene vergesst bitte
nicht dass Russland vor dem Krieg vor
allem ein großer Exporteur von Rohöl war
Gas Uran Waffen das alles war
zweitrangig das Geld kam hauptsächlich
aus dem Öl das war in der Vergangenheit
so und ist immer noch so Öl und seine
Derivate sind bei weitem der dominante
Exportschlager des Landes die erste
Frage wir uns stellen können lautet also
haben die Sanktionen hier funktioniert
nun theoretisch
ja aufgrund des Embargos der
Europäischen Union sind die europäischen
Abnehmer von russischem Öl praktisch
verschwunden Russland musste einen
großen Teil seines Rohöls auf andere
Märkte umleiten und musste dafür enorme
preisnachläse in Kauf nehmen das ist
schon tausend mal gesagt worden
um dieses ausbluten zu stoppen musste
sich Russland der von Saudi-Arabien
vorangetriebenen ölförderkürzung
anschließen diese zog eine Kürzung der
Produktion um etwa eine halbe Million
Barrel pro Tag Nachsicht und das zu
einer Zeit in der Russland jeden Penny
braucht den es bekommen kann 2 April
2023 Novak sagt dass Russland die
Kürzung der Ölproduktion um 500.000
Barrel pro Tag bis Ende des Jahres
verlängern will im Prinzip geht der
Kremel logischerweise davon aus dass der
Anstieg des Ölpreises als folg der
angebotsverringerung den
Produktionsrückgang ausgleichen wird
aber das ist eine andere Geschichte für
ein anderes Video denn obwohl die
Öleinnahmen der Regierung nun stark
zurückgegangen sind ist Russland nicht
nur weiterhin sein Öl los geworden
sondern auch die größten russischen
Unternehmen in dieser Branche darunter
einige staatliche Unternehmen wie rasnft
und Gasprom haben Geld verdient und ein
riesiges Vermögen von fast 200
Milliarden Dollar angehäuft also fast
200 Milliarden Euro die N und
größtenteils dem Kremmel zur Verfügung
stehen könnten aber okay gehen wir
Schritt für Schritt vor um diese ganze
Geschichte zu verstehen um zu ver stehen
warum die petrodollas trotz aller
Sanktionen weiterhin in der einen oder
anderen Form massiv nach Moskau
fließen erstens enthielt das europäische
Embargo für Rohöl einige Ausnahmen wir
sprechen z.B von russischem Öl das
Raffinerien erreicht die an der
druschbar Pipeline angeschlossen sind
eine der größten Pipelines der Welt
viele Raffinerien hatten keine
Alternativen also durfte das Rohöl
weiterfließen und das tut es noch immer
schaut euch z.B den Fall Tschechiens an
im Jahr 2021 machte es Öl 49% aller
Importe aus 2022 56% und dieses Jahr
65% 11 September 2023 russisches Öl
nimmt größten Anteil an tschechischen
Importen ein obwohl eine Reduktion
vorgesehen ist angeblich arbeiten sie
daran diese Situation zu ändern aber in
der Zwischenzeit rollt der Rubel das
Gleiche geschah in Bulgarien wo der
russische Ölkonzern Lil praktisch ein
Monopol in der Branche hatte aus diesem
Grund wurde auch diesem Land die
Erlaubnis erteilt weiterhin russisches
Ruhl zu importieren sogar auf dem
seeeweg für zwei weitere Jahre
allerdings muss man bedenken dass es
sich bei diesen Ländern nicht gerade um
die größten Ölverbraucher Europas
handelt aber auch klein vi macht
bekanntlich Mist zweitens es mag euch
überraschen aber russische ölgiganten
wie rasnft und Luk verfügen über Anteile
an refffinerien in Europa wir sprechen
von Raffinerien wie Seeland in den
Niederlanden an denen lookul mit 45%
beteiligt ist oder den drei anderen
Raffinerien die dasselbe Unternehmen in
Italien Bulgarien und Rumänien besitzt
oder
besaß
hier nutzen Sie die Tatsache aus dass Öl
aus dem Ural sehr billig gehandelt wurde
um all diese Raffinerien zu beliefern
Raffinerien die dann ihr Benzin ihr
Diesel und andere Derivate zu
Marktpreisen in Europa verkaufen und
zwar zu Preisen die himmelhoch waren das
erklärt warum einige Länder wie Italien
und Bulgarien ihre Käufe von russischem
Öl monatelang verdoppelt
[Musik]
haben die Gewinnspanne war einfach
gigantisch um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben wenn eine Raffinerie normalerweise
eine Gewinnspanne von $ hat wenn wenn
Sie ein Barrel Öl in Treibstoff
umwandelt vervielfachte sich diese
Gewinnspanne in diesen Raffinerien auf
40 bis 50 $ plötzlich wurden diese
Anlagen zu regelrechten goldmienen wenn
es eine forbsliste der lukrativsten
Raffinerien geäbe würden diese definitiv
auf dem Cover stehen sie waren super
profitabel und brachten ihren russischen
Eigentümern ein riesiges Vermögen ein
wir sprechen hier über einen
gigantischen Berg von Euros und Dollars
den die russischen Unternehmen dann mit
großer Sorgfalt über viele
Tochtergesellschaften und sich
überschneidende Unternehmen rund um den
Globus versteckt also lasst uns doch mal
auf Weltreise gehen um all diese
Verstecke ausfindig zu machen in dieser
Grafik könnt ihr die russischen
ölleferungen nach Europa im Jahr 2022
sehen obwohl das gesamtimimportvolumen
russischen Rohöls reduziert wurde gab es
keine Verringerung bei dem Öl das direkt
von Tochtergesellschaften russischer
Unternehmen gekauft wurde oder des Öls
aus der Pipeline die Ungaren und die
Tschechische Republik versorgt da habt
ihr es also Deutschland z.B hat zwei
Raffinerien enteignet die rasneft und
gastum gehörten allerdings nicht sofort
und bis dahin haben Sie eine Menge Geld
verdient dann wurden noch ein paar
andere Einrichtungen im Rahmen von Deals
verkauft was in vielen Fällen na ja den
Russen eben noch mal eine ganze Stange
Geld eingebracht
hat tatsache ist dass Russland auf diese
Weise eine Menge Devisen eingestrichen
hat vergess nicht dass die Regierung und
die Zentralbank ihre
reservetransaktionen in Dollar und Euro
eingeschränkt haben das gilt allerdings
nicht für die Unternehmen ob staatlich
oder privat mit anderen Worten wir haben
es hier mit einer Art öltrampolin zu tun
lasass mich euch eine Frage stellen wie
viel von Russlands Geld wurde
eingefroren nun die richtige Antwort
lautet etwa 300 Milliarden Dollar in
Fremdwährungen und wie viel haben die
Ölfirmen nun in anderthalb Jahren
gehortet 200 Milliarden okay sie konnten
den Gesamtbetrag also noch nicht
ausgleichen aber Putin hat auf jeden
Fall eine Menge Dollars bekommen um
seine Kriegsmaschine am Laufen zu halten
und damit kann er Chips über Kasachstan
importieren und moderne Maschinen über
Armenien oder Nordkorea Tonnen an
Munition Einkaufen okay es stimmt dass
viel von diesem Geld auch in anderen
Taschen landet aber was soll's wir reden
hier über Russland so war es doch schon
immer und so wird's auch immer sein
vergesst nicht dass wir über ein Land
reden indem die Regierung so weit geht
dass sie ihr eigenes privates Militär
aufstellt es besteht also kein Zweifel
daran dass man in Moskau die Formel
finden wird um das gesamte ölimperium
nach Belieben zu nutzen aber das meine
Lieben Zuschauer ist noch nicht alles es
gibt noch mehr Gründe warum der Fluss
der Dollars nach Russland nicht
abbricht denn drittens hat Russland ja
nach alternativen Märkten gesucht um
sein Öl loszuwerden wir haben schon oft
über diese Märkte gesprochen damit
meinen wir Länder wie China Indien und
sogar einige afrikanische Republiken der
Punkt ist dass wir über Länder sprechen
die sich nicht direkt der
Preisobergrenze angeschlossen haben die
von der G7 der Europäischen Union und
Australien festgelegt wurde aber das
vielleicht auffälligste hier ist nicht
dass diese Länder dem Abkommen nicht
beigetreten sind sondern dass der
westliche Plan auch nicht besonders gut
umgesetzt worden zu sein scheint was ich
damit meine nun verschiedenen
Schätzungen zufolge erfolgten den ersten
sechs Monaten des Jahres 2023 etwa die
Hälfte aller russischen Exporte von
pazifikhäfen aus und ihr Verkaufspreis
überstieg die Obergrenze okay das klingt
noch nicht außergewöhnlich aber jetzt
kommt der Hammer diese Deals wurden
nämlich mit Schiffen durchgeführt die
Unternehmen aus Ländern gehörten oder
durch sie versichert waren die die
Preisobergrenze unterschrieben hatten
wir sprechen hier vor allem über
Griechenland seht's euch an 17 April
2023 Griechen dominieren die russischen
Ölexporte laut dem
datenanalyseunternehmen vortexa wird die
tankerflotte die nach den Sanktionen am
russischen Handel beteiligt ist
überwiegend von Griechen betrieben um
euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
wovon wir spre allein in den ersten vier
Monaten des Jahres 2023 haben diese
Unternehmen russisches Rohöl im Wert von
mehr als 40 Milliarden Dollar
transportiert oder den Transport
versichert mit anderen Worten auf die
eine oder andere Weise wurde noch nicht
alles getan was möglich war ja die Idee
der Preisobergrenze ist das russisches
Öl weiterhin auf dem weltmark fließen
würde aber eben zu einem begrenzten
Preis und das wurde nur teilweise
erreicht aber das bringt uns natürlich
direkt zu einem absolut wichtigen
[Musik]
Thema denn ist euch vorhin nicht
irgendwas aufgefallen überlegt doch mal
all diese Unternehmen sind für Moskau
inzwischen absolut unfzichtbar es geht
nicht mehr darum ob sie mehr oder
weniger Rohöl verkaufen der Punkt ist
dass sie jetzt die Schlüssel zur
schatzrroe des russischen Volksvermögens
besitzen und wisst ihr was das bedeutet
wenn mittelfristig Alternative und
ausreichende Erdölquellen gefunden
werden können wir direkt gegen die
russischen Ölgesellschaften vorgehen und
ja das könnte dann wirklich ein
schrecklicher Schlag für Russland sein
die Frage ist also ob man das in Moskau
nicht weiß nun natürlich wissen sie es
aber so ist es nun mal dass in Moskau
nicht unbedingt die gllügsten Köpfe
sitzen hat sich auch darin gezeigt wie
sich die Russen von den ändern haben
über den Tisch ziehen lassen sie haben
ihnen super billiges Öl geliefert und
nun kommen sie noch nicht mal an die
vielen Milliarden die sie dafür bekommen
sollten heran die schlauen er halten Sie
einfach in Ihrem Land zurück aber diese
Geschichte ist der Art wild und auch
noch mit vielen anderen strategischen
Sektoren verknüpft Stichwort russische
Waffen dass sie ein eigenes Video
verdient hat und dieses könnt ihr euch
auf meinem neuen Kanal ansehen ihr
solltet es euch auf keinen Fall inehen
lassen also klickt jetzt auf den Link
oben rechts hinter isymbol danach könnt
ihr dieses Video ruhig zu Ende schauen
denn wie gesagt in Moskau sitzen nicht
unbedingt die schlausten Köpfe trotzdem
gibt es eine Strategie um dieser
Möglichkeit entgegenzuwiken sie fußt auf
drei Säulen erstens dass diese
Unternehmen so viel Geld wie möglich
verstecken zweitens tun sie das was sie
bereits im Handel tun nämlich mehr
Währungen Verbündete Länder nutzen seit
2022 ist z.B das Gewicht von Dollars und
Euros im russischen Handel von 80% auf
weniger als 50% gesunken etwas ähnliches
wird wahrscheinlich auch mit einem
großen Teil der Reserven der ölgiganten
passieren mit anderen Worten wir werden
bald eine Menge russischer Investitionen
außerhalb des Westens sehen und drittens
versuchen Sie das Haushaltsdefizit
zumindest zu begrenzen indem sie
gesetzliche Reformen verabschieden damit
diese Giganten mehr in die öffentlichen
Kassen einzahlen bisher waren z.B die
Steuern auf die Ölförderung an den Ural
Rohölpreis gekoppelt weshalb die
Einnahmen der Konzerne nach der
Einführung der Öl Preisobergrenze so
stark gesunken sind seitdem haben sich
die Regeln allerdings geändert auf diese
Weise wird der Handlungsspielraum
Moskaus größer und das erklärt dann
warum sich die Haushaltszahlen in den
letzten Monaten sogar verbessert
[Musik]
haben aber neben all diesen ölbezogenen
Techniken gibt es noch einen weiteren
Aspekt ich spreche vom sogenannten
eurasischen Kreislauf Russland nutzt
seine Nachbarländer um internationale
Beschränkungen zu umgehen das ist z.B
der Fall Armeniens die Exporte des
kleinen kaukasuslandes mit nur 2,7
Millionen Einwohner nach Russland haben
sich vervierfacht und gleichzeitig haben
sich die armenischen Einfuhren aus der
EU und den USA Großbritannien und Japan
verdreifacht oder seht euch mal diese
Grafik an hier seht ihr wie die Exporte
aus Deutschland ein bestimmtes
zentralasiatisches Land in die Höhe
geschossen sind und wisst ihr was das
bedeutet nun es ist genau das wonach es
aussieht ich bin mir sicher dass ihr
jetzt verstehen könnt warum die Moskauer
Edelrestaurants immer noch ausgebucht
sind warum den Einkaufszentren kein
großer Mangel herrscht und warum die
Dinge in Russland an der Oberfläche
anscheinend nicht so schlecht laufen
dennoch sollten wir mal Inn halalten nur
damit sich niemand täuschen
lässt alles was wir diesem Video gesehen
haben waren Tricks Schummeleien
flugstrategien mit denen Putin die
Sanktion vorerst umgehen kann aber auf
lange Sicht wird die russische
Wirtschaft sehr darunter leiden all
diese Produkte die jetzt ins Land kommen
sind viel teurer ausländische
Investitionen und der mit ihnen
verbundene wichtige naau transansfer
werden für lange Zeit ausbleiben und
junge Fachkräfte werden alles tun um aus
dem Land zu fliehen erstens um eine
Zukunft zu haben und zweitens um nicht
im Krieg verheizt zu werden langfristig
wird sich all dies auf die ohnehin schon
katastrophale Produktivität des Landes
auswirken die geschilderte Problematik
zeigt jedoch auch dass
sanktionsprogramme dynamisch bleiben
müssen und sich den Tricksereien des
Gegenübers stets und schnell anpassen
müssen im Moment überlebt Putin noch
aber irgendwann werden ihm die Tricks
ausgehen die Frage ist also was sollten
eure Meinung nach die westlichen
Verbündeten der Ukraine tun sollten Sie
dieses Thema ernster nehmen würdet ihr
die Vermögen russischer staatsuntern
nemen generell zu beschlagnahmen
versuchen auf welche Weise könnte Moskau
noch eurer Meinung nach für seine
Aggression bestraft werden schreibt uns
eure Einschätzung bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter diesem Video und
vergesst bitte auch nicht auf meinem
neuen Kanal vorbeizuschauen den ich euch
hinter dem i oben rechts und in der
Videobeschreibung verlinke ich hoffe
dass euch dies Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht dabei auch was gelernt
habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like te
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es
auch mit ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jeder Zeit über eine Spende von
euch mit uns dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]